We now know a lot about color, but nothing yet about materials. Say, we have a
red ball. How do we make the GPU compute how the lights in the scene and the
ball's material interact, so that the ball looks real. When performing
interactive rendering, the standard way to think about a material's appearance
is as a few different components added together, emissive, ambient, diffuse, and
specular. The idea of the emissive term is that it's for coloring glowing
objects. For example, a lightbulb has its own color and other light sources
don't really affect it. In reality, the emissive term is simply a way to add in
some constant color regardless of the lighting conditions. The second component,
ambient, is a fudge factor. Something added in so objects look better especially
in areas that are not directly lit. You'll see it in various systems controlled
in various ways. When all is said and done, the ambient term helps compute a
constant color value that is added to the fragment's final color value. The
emissive and ambient terms are kept separate, as they fulfill different
functions, and often have different controls. For example, three.js allows you
to set an ambient light that affects all materials with an ambient term.
Remember that we made a simplification with lights in a scene. We assume photons
come only from lights, and don't bounce around. In reality, photons would
reflect from the floor to the bottom of the sphere to our eye. However, with our
assumption, the lower part of the sphere doesn't get any light and so would look
black. The ambient term gives us at least some color in these types of areas
instead of being entirely black. The diffuse and specular components are
computed based on the lights in the scene. While the emissive and ambient are
essentially independent of these, the diffuse term can be though of as a flat,
matte finish, and specular can be thought of as the shininess of an object. In
terms of computation, the specular term is also affected by the viewers
location. While the diffuse term is determined only by each lights location.